a festival of summer sports kicks off
tonight with the euros
and the country is ready to serve
hopes are high every day brings us
closer
to freedom day when all restrictions
will be lifted
but that target date of 21st of june
is at risk the delta variant is driving
a surge in infections the hospitality
industry's bounced back
incredibly well um it's been it's been
hard it's been tough but i think people
want to eat people on a drink and they
definitely want to watch football and we
just want to make sure when we do open
that it will stay that way and not have
to close again because it's the opening
the closing
that is destructive for the industry
the number of delta variant cases has
increased
from 12 431
to 42 323
in just a week that's an increase of 243
percent
the delta variant first identified in
india was found in the uk in march it
now accounts
for 96 of cases
public health england estimates that
it's 64
more transmissible within households
than
previous variants and vaccines are on
average between
15 to 20 percent less effective
against this strain of covid after the
first
dose compared to the alpha variant
i think it would be gravely negligent
for the government to move ahead with
removing restrictions on the 21st june
given the data now and what we've known
for several weeks
scientists like deputy gurdasani have
been joined by the bma
and nhs leaders in calling on the
government to delay
lifting restrictions they say
hospitalization rates in the northwest
up by 66 are a stark warning
you're not just talking about delaying
freedom day on the 21st of june but
you're calling for more
urgent interventions now we're seeing
exponential growth of cases very rapidly
the current r
is around 1.3 and in some places it's
1.5
uh and we're seeing rapid growth in
cases and hospitalizations particularly
in the northwest
so unless we do something to curb spread
now we're still heading towards a large
number of hospitalizations potentially
overwhelming the
nhs and large numbers of cases for long
covered
the government is facing pressure not
just from businesses
but a public keen to see life returned
to normal
a lot of the older people is going into
hospitals there's the main reason why we
went to lockdown in the first place so
if a lot of those people have been like
both vaccinations and they shouldn't be
that bad
i think they should just go along with
it unless there's a huge spike in deaths
then i think this should just go along
with it for the sake of the economy and
the sake of people sanity
for now the planning continues but the
party
might just have to be put on hold for a
little bit
longer josh's sky news